Now that we've seen solving a system of equations using substitution and
elimination, let's see how we can use those skills to solve some more
interesting problems. Let's try one with interest. You invest $10,000 in two
funds, one of the funds pays at 7.5% and another fund pays at 8%. You earned a
total interest of $787.50. So, how much money did you invest at each rate? Maybe
you lost your tax forms or maybe you don't have your bank statements. Either
way, you can use algebra to help figure out how much money you invested in your
trade. When creating a system of equations, we know that we need two variables,
x and y. This question actually indicates what variables we should use. We're
looking for how much money was invested at 7.5% and at 8%. So that's going to be
our two variables. I'm going to go ahead and let x be the amount we invested at
7.5% and y be the amount we invested at 8%. Using these two variables, what
equation could you write involving the amount of money you invested? You want to
use an amount plus the amount should equal your total amount. Write that
equation here. And remember, it should involve x and y.